[Música]
una historia de un sueño que se hizo
realidad yo empecé algo diecisiete años
jugando y quería necesitaba ser un algún
negocio para mantenerme mi mamá me dijo
no te voy a seguir manteniendo no puedo
seguir contigo y tienes que empezar a
ganarte la vida de buscar la manera en
la que lo vas a hacer
fue un parteaguas muy importante en mi
vida pero al final hoy doy empleo a más
de 4000 personas
tengo un periódico que es el financiero
en alianza con bloomberg y somos un
referente muy importante en nuestro país
cuando yo era joven and decente yo no
vengo de una familia
cursos
urgentes de dinero por herencia sino
clase media
empezando a buscar cómo hacerlo si yo
seguía pensando en alguna estrategia
para poder hacer un negocio y me metí en
un problema en esa ciudad un amigo me
prestó una moto me la llevo me la roban
y se la tenía que pagar no tenía tampoco
dinero es para ti gracias
entonces vuelvo
logré llegar a un acuerdo con ella
y ha puesto el dinero pero la puso a
trabajar porque yo tenía que hacer que
se hable si el dinero
obviamente yo era ni siquiera mayor no
podía tener un trabajo formal entonces
ella llamó a todos los contactos y
conocidos para que de alguna manera me
llegan un trabajo me empecé a descubrir
a mí mismo que las casualidades se
empiezan a dar y empezó esto por la
personalidad y que me robaron al mundo
mi madre me puso a trabajar por tres
meses tenía millón de estar cumpliendo
con mi colegio con trabajo para poder
terminar de pagar cuando termine de
pagar en la moto que fue algo simbólico
me di cuenta que me gustaba trabajar que
era una persona y yo era una persona que
podía servir para algo más
y aclaro recuerda que yo os voy a servir
para algo más que para estudiar es ir
haciendo cosas
empecé a buscar de qué manera hacían
negocios
en aquel entonces firman el mejor
trabajo del facebook en una revista
política de nuestro país yo empecé a
llorar que hacía todos los mandados y
las cosas
mi permiso de conducir y entonces me
dice la gente oye sabes manejar si me
dice mi jefe y luego sí pero cómo es que
que ya tengo que hacer como ha visto que
nos ayudes en la madrugada a repartir al
personal al trabajar como atrás en su
casa de regreso yo me di cuenta que
conocía todas las secretarias de las
oficinas de gobierno me conocía a toda
la gente a la que diario me entregaba la
revista porque la época ni siquiera
había internet entonces
yo los veía día me tenía un trato
directo con las secretarias con todos y
lo que sabía que había un gran comercio
alrededor de todas las éstas son
oficinas y secretarias y gentes de
intendencia
vendían cosas entre ellos entonces se me
hizo fácil entrar en el centro pollero
ver y comprar joyería por kilos y hace
muestrarios y entonces llevárselos
entonces empecé a ofrecerles joyería a
consignación y después de eso yo les
ellos me pagaban me a la quincena y
obvio por la mitad el 50 por ciento para
ellos por ciento para el primer pago y
el segundo era entonces
vuestro preguntan un mundo lo importante
de vendedores y al cabo de un año no
había fundado en aquella época de
ordenación desigual
es muy fácil que vendiendo comida podía
ser millonario y va a crecer iba a ser
empresario
pero si quieren una crisis siempre la
gente como siempre necesitamos alimentos
voy a abrir una comida abrió un pequeño
local de ikea les cuento que me gasté
mismo 150 mil pesos prendido muy bonito
local era todo y nos separamos solo
entonces será verdaderamente preocupante
porque yo tenía compromiso de pagar
pardilla 2 para comidas y todo lo de la
historia de circunstancias como antes
cambiando después en la vida sino como
empezar a ofrecer comidas por 7 pesos a
cada uno de los locales que había
alrededor de mi negocio entonces yo iba
a la papelería a los salones de belleza
en nuestras guarderías en las boleterías
a las gasolinerías a todos los negocios
alrededor de mi negocio y por siete
pesos yo les ofrecía
comidas sustentaba el pago de la renta
del hogar con mi negocio de joyería pero
se estaba acabando el dinero al final
terminé haciendo mínimos con comida con
joyería pero
terminé repartiendo como 120 comidas
diarias repartiendo de acción y local no
había negocio pero yo repartía lo que
fuera rentable mi negocio yo de lunes a
viernes
me pasaba trabajando desde la mañana
adaptar hasta la noche muy muy muy duro
porque hacía compras los lunes para
tener comer la comida para toda la
semana y llevar a la central de abastos
de su tía tenía todo
yo llegaba gente cocinaba yo repartía
las comidas y lo único que quería hacer
era descansar
seguro con recuerden la para la vuelta
la cual en un momento me decepcionó pero
gracias a eso nació lo que les conté
gracias a eso es permitido en el negocio
de las telecomunicaciones y gracias a
eso aprendí a hacer más cosas en mi vida
me llevan a ser uno de los empresarios
más jóvenes importantes de mi país
entonces qué ocurrió decirle al centro
de dónde reparaban televisores que si me
dejaba con el mundo una pequeña
cartulina en donde dijera que vendían
que venía una antena para volver
y dejó ponerlo en el teléfono yo seguía
entregando las comidas todos los días
entregando
preguntando quién es la verdad no sabía
nada manejar en cambiarle el refrán y
siempre me ha gustado la televisión y
electrónica entonces sabía operar al
perfectas interiormente la parabólica y
me dice oyentes de un cliente que le
cayó un rayo en su casa se le dará
rondos los televisores pero se le dañó
también el sistema de la parabólica
podría repararlo vamos a ver lo que
tiene un tipo completamente diferente a
la mía problema total fácilmente sino
por lo que llevar los equipos que tengo
que checarlo lo que no quería
llevárselos a mi casa revisarlos en la
noche que sin tanta presión y que nadie
me viera y entonces regresar y decirle
si se arregla vamos y empiezo a buscar
quién me ayude a repararlos se encuentra
una persona digo oye ningún cliente que
tiene una antena parabólica dañada y que
quiero arreglar lo que podría ser
orientar cómo hacerlo yo me dedico a las
antenas parabólicas 30 y bien vaya que
ahorita no le entiendo este sistema
nuevo que salió hoy listo ayuda total de
que encontrarán todas estas personas no
los negocios con él
empieza a enseñar a utilizarlo
y luego a pedir que lo va a pasar la
función del cliente si se acepta de
víctima le digo pagar al que me había
llevado mi cliente de las comidas que le
dijera su cliente que repararla el plan
de la parabólica en aquella que costaba
30 mil pesos 30 mil pesos era lo que yo
se obtura va en un mes en mi negocio de
comidas y respondieron las espantosas
y entonces no excepto en el presupuesto
entonces me ayudó a preparar esto en
favor de que venga conmigo
entonces si no hay problema pero lo
apagas total de que lo logré hacer
funciona muy bien
en un viaje a estados unidos por unos
receptores y empecé a traerlo y empecé a
vender y uno de los principales
proveedores en todo el país de vender
sistemas antenas parabólicas
ya sabían la historia es mucho más
chistosa temper mi mamá me quería correr
de la casa porque ahora las personas de
servicio por favor no conteste el
teléfono del teléfono te pido que esto
es una empresa seria en general
y este es mi cuarto más dormido hasta
las 11 de la mañana
una empresa tenía 17 18 años
para mover un logotipo porque se van a
salir las computadoras que ustedes se
acuerdan de los cursos de de microsoft
venía un logotipo de una parabólica lo
siguiente me lo voy a agarrar y entonces
los tipos de compensar vamos a poner
desplegados en los periódicos el segundo
mando en todos lados y condensar es una
gran compañía gigantesca que tiene
muchos empleados lo visualizaba sí no
mis dos amigos
en pesos bueno vamos pero tú sabes
instalarlas y yo diseña mente entonces
empezaba con mis amigos a instalar las
antenas todo y poco a poco solucionando
terreno
se empezó a cavar
y entonces que voy a hacer ahora me
tengo que dedicar
y allí ya con la experiencia que tenía
la gente que yo había conocido me empecé
a meter en la parte de televisión
profesional y ahora voy a vender
transmisores parabólicas
el equipo de edición total empecé a
vender equipo profesional de televisión
a poco tiempo cabo de 10 años más rápido
el 95% de las televisiones en el país
habían sido integradas por condensa tico
entonces con texas se había vuelto a
alumbrar el indicador de los dicen tener
otro problema ya tenía dinero pero ya lo
tenía marcado porque no se hacían
diarias televisoras entonces yo tenía
que buscar ahora con nueva solución que
me llevara a seguir creciendo poco
entonces en vez de abrir oficinas en
centroamérica
estaba creciendo y empezamos a aceptar
visor
centroamérica hicimos un gran dt h
hicimos muchas muchas más
instalaciones y empezamos a crecer en
diferentes países en latinoamérica sin
llegar a verse
y empezamos a prender cámaras a los
bancos a las industrias
las ciudades se hagan muchas cosas vamos
a vender cámaras de circuito cerrado de
televisión y entonces con que sean
preciosos ramas de servicios pero que
quería yo y funcionar en los niños de
telecomunicaciones porque yo decía a ver
cómo es posible encontrar hacemos todo
esto son
estamos atrás de la información de los
medios pero no participamos de manera
activa
bueno un periódico
entonces total empezó a buscar canales
en periódicos y me encuentro con el
periódico financiero
que tenía una excelente y si ha tenido
una excelente reputación o será una gran
oportunidad porque su fundador había
fallecido logró contactar con la familia
cárdenas le dijo quiero comprar su
proyecto dice no nos dan de panamá
yo me dedico a la televisión quiero
llevar el periódico a la televisión y
total de que decida venderme el
periódico y les quiero decir que en los
últimos 50 años en nuestro país va la
transacción más importante que existe un
medio de comunicación
compró el periódico financiero yo no
sabía nada de periódicos sólo también
recuerdo de repartidas revistas y de ahí
inició todo esto es esa constancia que
yo me había dado dinero para comprar una
comunicación la exposición es un
presidente y director general del
periódico financiero y no tiene ni idea
de cómo operar un periódico
total de que empiezo a viajar alrededor
del mundo y en uno de estos viajes a los
principales diarios más importantes en
diferentes partes del mundo nueva york
visit obviamente no se tienen
tecnológicamente se dedicaba a lo mismo
que yo a lo mismo
y cuando ves un incendio identificado de
una visita de dos minutos
quiero conocer a este señor más
prüfer sí pero él no lo atiende gente es
el mejor de nueva york ahora y ya no
tiene que hablar
yo quiero traer a bloomberg
bueno al cabo de tres semanas estaba el
señor le estaba proponiendo que me diera
que me diera por favor la oportunidad de
poner mi periódico en su plataforma y
que su plataforma de socios partner es
uno de los importantes del mundo
entonces llegamos a un acuerdo y hoy el
financiero bloomberg es una plataforma
más de las más importantes en nuestro
país y entonces
esta es la historia que me ha llevado a
todos los casos en los cuales es un
regalo de mi mamá
y hoy le doy las gracias a mi mamá
porque me enseñó a aplicar algo que no
sabía de mí
y el éxito o yo estaba metido condensado
en el mundo de las telecomunicaciones
somos líderes lo que hacemos
tenemos la plataforma del pericón
financiero y como les comenté al
principio de mi plática hoy damos empleo
a más de 4.000 personas
todo esto nos lleva a decirles que si
persiguen sus sueños se puede hacer
realidad hoy mismo
[Aplausos]